before i get a picture on the board
can you help me fill in the rest of this
because i assume actually i don't assume
i went around and i saw a lot of people
completed the table of values sometimes
even further than this
so can you give me some numbers let's go
either like one decimal place or a
fraction or whatever yeah
oh that's one six and a half six and a
half okay who did five
five point two five point two
approximately anyone do six
okay and the last one that i've got yeah
three and a quarter yeah cool okay good
so what's going on here um how would you
describe these numbers are they getting
bigger or getting smaller
they're getting smaller they're all each
one
is smaller than the last one okay yeah
super what else do you notice
oh this is going to be a super question
that's right ask it anyway
so they're 26 in total
this whole commercial at the bottom well
you would have gotten a different set of
numbers but they'll be doing much the
same thing though won't they
yeah okay they're all reducing now this
is interesting as well by the way
they're not just getting smaller have a
look for instance at the gap between
here and here versus
the gap between here and here
do you notice that yeah look see
when i went from just just one person
having it
to having to share it between two of us
we felt that
it was a big hit right but here the
difference is minor it's not even
a whole chocolate it's 0.6 of a
chocolate
right and so the gaps between these are
getting
smaller it's smaller smaller okay
now quick question for you a thought
experiment if you will
if i had a million people
to share this box of chocolates with
okay
how many chocolates would we each get
0.000
it's gonna be forever
like in real life no one would get
anything
right it would just everyone would grab
for it and then there'd be nothing left
at the end
right but mathematically
aha you have calculators right so you
can actually work out
how am i going to how do you work out
where did you get this 13 from
and where did you get these numbers from
26 divided by
the number of people right that is how
many chocolates
each person got right so therefore in
this scenario
how many chocolates are they going to
get it's going to be 26 divided by
a million which i actually would love to
know what it is zero point
how many zeros four four four point
like that yeah yeah yeah okay
so you see we can consider this
mathematically even though
yeah practically speaking we're not
going to get anything
so now come to this here right do you
remember how we drew up a table of
values but we're like oh it's chocolate
and it's people
right well usually we call these things
x and y
right we usually call this the x
right that's your top row there and this
is y so now what you're really staring
at right here
what you're staring at is the rule
except i just need to phrase it right
the chocolate is the y value and people
are the x value this this is the
equation
that's going to give us this shape now
i'm just going to quickly draw it for
you okay
looks like this
okay and that's what i saw a lot of
people draw which is fantastic
but there are some things missing okay
for instance let's think about this guy
okay
you notice it's tiny really really tiny
right but at least mathematically
speaking
no matter how many people you share with
you can share with every person on the
planet
seven billion is where we're at now
right mathematically in your calculator
everyone's still going to get a tiny
tiny little bit of chocolate
right is that the thing that works
about the metal
that's right that's right that's exactly
right it's about sharing
something amongst a very large group of
people right so you end up with a tiny
amount but here's the important thing
right
mathematically these numbers never get
to zero right so this graph is going to
go
down and down and down down but it's
never going to hit this axis we had a
word for this
we developed it on this graph do you
remember it
starts with an a what's happening over
here
it's approaching it's a weird word right
let's let's draw on to your graphs
because you've got a graph that looks
like mine right
there is this dotted line here it's an
asymptote
remember that okay
it's an asymptote it's never gonna get
to zero
approach and approach forever
now let's keep pushing on this because
there's something else on this graph
right
do you notice what happens
going the other way right
um this is this is like zero people here
right you can't divide 26 chocolates
among zero people
um you can't divide things among zero
groups right into zero groups
so therefore this this graph not only is
it trying to approach zero over here
but it's trying to approach this graph
and it never gets there
it approaches and approaches and it
never actually closes the gap
right so therefore there's an
asymptote up and down as well
right so this horizontal asymptote has
an equation of y
equals zero and the vertical one has an
equation
x equals zero very good
okay we're almost done the graph is
almost complete
okay um you might notice on these graphs
right i had these extra bits
that are included what happens when
things are negative right
what do you suppose would happen you see
again this is pushing back on that
question of
things you can do in maths that
physically impossible right
what would happen if my people number
how many people i was sharing once
what would happen if it was negative
where would this graph
go
what do you reckon darcy
um okay so you've got you've got four
sections right we call them quadrants
because there's four of them
so you reckon down here
okay let's push on this it is going
gonna be down there but what's it going
to be doing there
okay let's do it like this okay it's
still gonna follow this same rule
right y equals 26 divided by x
chocolate equals 26 divided by people
okay so get your calculator out get your
calculator i i need a few people to help
me here
okay i want some negative values okay
26 let's go um negative 1 negative 2
negative 3 negative 4 negative 5
negative 6 negative 7. i think that'll
be enough to see and if
other people could beat them to it
that's fine what do we get for negative
1
negative 26. okay sorry i'm going to
write this in a particular spot
okay i'm going to write it here negative
26 okay good
next one if i'm trying to share among
negative two people
what happens negative thirteen negative
thirteen
okay interesting negative eight point
six negative eight and in fact
two-thirds oh negative six 6.5
you're starting to perhaps see a pattern
right
it's doing the same thing isn't it right
except
it's negative and it's going in the
other direction
these are negative 1 negative 2 negative
3 which is actually going
right to left okay so in fact
darcy is right it is in this area and
this is what it's doing
yes there you go
all right this is a linear graph this is
a parabola
this is an exponential the name of this
shape
its cool special function funky name is
the hyperbola
okay now not to be confused with in
english the figure of speech which is
hyperbole which is a um which is an
exaggeration
over exaggeration right like like that
donut cost me a million dollars
was expensive wasn't that expensive